i think what i'm what i get excited by
every morning for the past decade since
i
started my entrepreneurial journey is is
creating the impossible is is
is creating the one thing that you think
to be impossible
and bringing people around it welcome to
20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford let's talk social
meet jonathan ruz friedman the ceo and
founder at supersocial
john is an entrepreneur and company
builder he is the ceo and founder of
super social with the mission to inspire
people to socialize
play and create in the metaverse
starting with roblox backed by
industry-leading investors
super social's ambition is to play an
instrumental role in shaping the next
era of interactive entertainment
prior to super social he co-founded kano
a computer company recognized by fastco
magazine as one of the world's most
innovative consumer electronics
companies
israeli born living in the us with his
wife carrie jonathan russ friedman thank
you for joining me how are you
i'm really good michael thanks for
having me on this show i'm so excited to
have you here are you
in new york right now i am actually as
we speak at the moment i am in columbus
ohio in the midwest of the the us
wow what brings you to columbus ohio
well it's my we we spent a bunch of time
last year during covid uh we live in
brooklyn but we came here for
uh for a few months and then we decided
to uh to do that again
you know new york is not really the same
at the moment so we thought let's let's
come here again for a few for a bit of
time and
and see how it goes so columbus ohio at
the moment amazing so i'm going to ask
for some recommendations later about
columbus ohio
but before that uh jonathan there's so
so many amazing things that i want to
talk about i want to talk about
engagement to game creation
creativity you know the this whole world
of of gaming and
you know the companies that you founded
from from sosu to coda interactive to
kind of computing
uh to now a super social which is behind
roblox i had even no idea i've been
hearing about this game for so long i
had no idea that that you're behind it i
believe i i just thought that you have
like 18 million
reviews or something on the on the play
store alone
something uh unbelievable but jonathan
even before all that you met your wife
on a random encounter in a bus
in athens what was that all about
yeah you know i think the i discovered
that life is really uh
all about these serendipitous moments of
meeting people
uh either in life or business some of
the best thing that happened to me in
life
happened like that and meeting my wife
was no was no
was no different we were both in a
conference with a by a company called
wpp one of the largest
advertising companies in the world and
they were an investor in my first
company kano
and i went to that conference in 2015
and toward the end of the year
and after four days of the conference on
the on the bus on the way back to the
airport i sat next to this really
wonderful woman
we started talking i i discovered she's
from originally from columbus ohio
but lives in new york and we we kind of
stayed in touch
and only after a year and a half
actually we reconnected and met again in
in
in san francisco and and immediately
everything clicked and
we got married you know we got engaged
after a few after six months
so it all started on a bus it all
started on a bus that that's that's a
remarkable i love that jonathan how do
you get into
the world of gaming i know that you
spent some time in the idc
uh you were you know the in the alumni
association of the desert
entrepreneurship program
you're also the chief of staff to the
chief of staff to the president of
kettle so your
your engagement with understanding about
that you know engagement and leadership
stems
way back you go you went from gaming
you're also in stickers for sneakers
right
how do you even get into this whole
industry
yeah you know i think the journey
started with being
getting into the zell program that was
really sort of the milestone that
changed the course of
the trajectory um and you've been you
know you've interviewed lyat aronson who
is a
close friend and a mentor and a big part
why i wanted to join the zell program
and
at this hill program i really fell in
love not just with the notion of
building something new
but launching something new and building
a team and a company
around that you know back then i was not
really into entrepreneurship i was 23
years old
and i didn't really think that that's
going to be a direction no one really
talked about startups too often it was
2008.
um but then i kind of fell in love i got
into the program we started this new
venture
stickers for snickers which we learned a
lot about about product development
that sort of been the the a really nice
stepping stone to join a company like
ketter where i was chief of staff
the president of the company and really
learned a lot about industrial design
mass manufacturing
global business leadership big business
and to be honest after that it was kind
of pretty abundantly clear that i want
to be a company builder
and then you know a month after i
finished with kedar january 2013
i moved to london and i started kano and
and the rest is history so that was sort
of what got me into entrepreneurship i
fell in love with the notion of building
an organization
building a product building something
new on your own
and and making people happy through that
so that's sort of the
the the genesis of how i got to where i
am i i love the making hat people happy
part can you extract maybe
one or two key things that you can
recall back from your time with qatar
you know being the chief of staff to the
president of a company that is yielding
over a billion dollars in revenue
you know it's a daunting task i remember
from my days in 8200 always the chief of
staff to
you know the the high ranks they're
working i've never seen people work so
hard
and they you i mean in some ways you are
the president
because you're you you have to be
aligned with with with the person in
charge and and it's
much more than just you know managing
the day-to-day things it's really being
as a part of the think tank so what are
some you know of the experiences that
really
has made you understand what type of
leader and entrepreneur you want to be
yeah you know i was really really
privileged to work for
an incredible human being uh center tal
who was
the president of the keto group and you
know
incredible emotional intelligence uh
really smart
business acumen in terms of what
takes people what makes business work
how to create win-win situation not what
with team babers but also
with business collaborators um having
the foresight
and the creativity to think about new
product ideas differently in a way that
the market doesn't
necessarily look at and i think above
all
also taking that operational excellence
that a company like ketter had
you know if i look at all of these
different things that i took from
ketter and learning from tal and and
other peoples in the organization
you know these are things that really
served me well when we went and built a
new computer
company you know you need to remember i
started kano at the age of 29
a computer company i didn't know
anything about building a company i
didn't know anything about building
computers
i didn't know anything about
manufacturing in china we had to figure
out all of those things and
and i think being part of a company that
ships over
you know 200 000 containers of plastic
products across the world
and and billions of dollars of revenue
every year really gave me the confidence
that
going into building a computer i'm going
to figure it out i'm going to go to
china i'm going to learn how to
manufacture computers and
and electronics i'm going to figure out
how to build a team
of course i've made a lot of mistakes
throughout the journey of you know
building kano and other things as well
but but those experiences with ketter
and seeing what
a large-scale excellent business being
run and built
really helped me in in sort of making
the first steps
as not just as an entrepreneur and a
founder but also as an executive
right so it was all about getting your
hands dirty at that point right and
getting that firsthand experience
understanding that it's
it's real it's about getting their hands
dirty even if you want to become you
know running a thousand person company
and and i think that what i've been
observing is that i've been talking to
people that are running
you know thousands that are managing
thousands of people but it all boils
down to
their core experiences you know i keep
thinking back to alibaba and jack ma's
upbringing you know standing outside of
the hotel teaching
tourists how to speak english or giving
them or
showing them around so that he can learn
english right it's all about those
experiences
that really make you as a leader right
there is a great picasso quote which i i
always remind to myself
and picasso said i always do
that which i do not know so i may learn
how to do it exactly
exactly that's it yeah that's kind of
the essence of it how do you
find yourself as a market leader
you know at the cutting edge of
entertainment
you're creating a multitude of companies
that are
dealing with entertainment dealing with
gaming what is sort of the the
part of you that it understands okay i
really want to build stuff that makes
people happy
and through engaging products i'm gonna
make that happen
yeah you know when i when i when i think
about a new venture
and when i think about the genesis of
starting companies like kano or encoder
and super social now
i think for me it's always start with
what is the value
what are we actually going to make
people be able to do what is going to be
fun for them what is going to add
value to their lives when we thought
about kano it wasn't about
hey let's build the computer because
people are just going to want another
computer
it was about how do we use computers and
technology
to empower young people to be creative
with technology and learn by doing by
themselves instead of just
using the tech and when we think about
super social and why we decided to start
super
social it was in the middle of a
pandemic super social was born
in june first last year the pandemic two
billion people are out of school
and what i think we realized was if we
look down the road five ten years down
the road it was really the
understanding that the notion of human
connection in a virtual world
the notion of human expression in a
virtual world is really going to shift
and change in the next decade
and we wanted as a company and as
builders we wanted to build experiences
and virtual worlds for this new
generation that is going to explore
and and experience human connection and
creative expression
in a whole new way and i think
accidentally not being a game
entrepreneur before
i recognize as a gamer and where the
world is going that virtual world or
gameplay experiences is going to be a
fantastic
way to reimagine those human connections
and how do we allow and empower people
at any age
to creatively express themselves and
that was the genesis of why we decided
to start super social
in the middle of epidemic which was a
you know a big a big undertaking
so obviously getting raising your seed
run from intel capital
and war and warner music group during
you know
with a company that you're creating
during the pandemic but that's
impressive but even more impressive is
the feed that you're taking on because
it sounds to me
that it's a lot of responsibility what
you're saying here taking responsibility
for the
way that people are going to be
interacting in a new environment in a
new age
that is predominantly virtual and being
the platform that that is being done on
that is a lot of responsibility like i
would be scared to take that
responsibility honestly
so obviously it's just as exciting but
tell me a little bit about how you're
thinking through this
well first of all i think what's really
um i'm the type of entrepreneur that i
love building
on on on the shoulders of giants you
know with kano we built on the raspberry
pi which was a really incredible
invention
which saved us a lot of time and
resources and we could have focused on
building the actual product experience
i think what we were doing with super
social is pretty similar you know this
platform roblox is is one of the fastest
growing
kind of gaming environments in the world
it's almost as if you would think
facebook in unity had a child it would
have been roblox
170 million monthly active users access
their platform every day every month
they have the game engine they have the
distribution they have the audience
and so instead of going and building
your own technology platform that other
companies have spent two decades
building
what we said we're gonna go and build on
the shoulders of these giants
and we're really excited and and
privileged to be building on a platform
like roblox so we can focus on
building those virtual worlds with
engagement and excitement and
inspiration
to bring different people together
across captivating stories
unique social gameplay mechanics and
virtual world that will empower you to
express yourself creatively through
games this is what we're focusing on and
i think if you
if you read a report like arc invest
the famous investment organization if
you read the report about what is going
to be the next cutting-edge technology
among a.i and and deep learning and
autonomous vehicles you're actually
going to see in the recent report
virtual worlds because we now recognize
everyone recognize that building these
engaging virtual worlds where we as
humans can manifest ourselves
through digital avatars and build
our experience in the world as people
and as creators through these virtual
worlds
this is going to be a massive frontier
in the next couple of decades
and by the way it doesn't matter if you
access those virtual world through your
mobile phone
through a vr through ar it's not the
point the point is
those virtual worlds are the evolution
of the internet they're going to be the
next big
utility and a lot of amazing human
experiences will be created on those
platforms
i completely agree and i think that
what's what's remarkable for me as a
bystander you know i'm
i'm i'm growing up in this transitional
generation right where
you know my generation growing up we
weren't like hardcore gamers like now
but we
but we were enough technologically
enthused that we understand so for me
i'm very much able to grasp this
idea that yes the future is all about
virtual worlds it's about allowing
anybody anywhere anytime anyplace
to create their own world to have a
presence in a virtual world and be
in the same world as their fellow peers
in whatever age groups around the world
at the same time you still have you know
a
few generations of resistance that are
saying what do you mean virtual world
you know we have this world you know we
don't
we don't want virtual worlds and so
you're there is this you know
interesting transitional gap but i
couldn't agree more i'm assuming that
you don't expect
to reach 170 million monthly users
and reach the the crazy traction that
you've had or was this all part of a
great master plan that you had
yeah look i think obviously we we we are
privileged that we are building for a
platform that or
that has that audience right and i think
if i look at an analogy
uh uh in the early days of facebook in
2008 2010 when facebook opened their
social api to other creators those
creators like zynga
like playfish like a lot of those
creators really enjoyed building on a
platform that already built that social
graph and i think that's what's really
unique about roblox in comparison to
other platform
you know roblox has built that social
graph that audience
multiple different ages who come to the
platform anyway every day
and i think as super social we are
focusing on
what type of games and experiences and
virtual worlds we can create
to really bring as many as these
millions of people as possible
every day to come and explore in our
world and
create and creatively express themselves
in our world this is really the task and
this is why we're thinking about it so
much more than a game in a nutshell the
future of games
in our mind is so much more than just a
quote-unquote game and this is what i
think is the big shift
right i think that the way that you're
approaching this and saying we're not
building a game we're building
a world we're building a universe right
in which people can create their own
virtual worlds you know it could
it could you know then diverge into you
know a million different pathways
based on that same platform that same
core identity and core belief that
we are headed into a place that people
are going to be creating their virtual
worlds and and they're going to find
this positive engagement through that
what are some things that you're keeping
in mind you know
as the ceo and co-founder of this as you
know now a person who is thinking
forward about this whole industry what
are some things that you're keeping in
mind
well i think what we need to keep in
mind we need to keep in mind that
the it's not just about building things
that are fun and incredibly engaging i
think that's a challenging and of itself
but i think there is going to be a need
to develop
what is that virtual world based
civility
how do we expect and want people to
behave in these new virtual worlds if
you're going to express yourself through
this
digital avatar right michael and you
might have multiple different avatars
you might have an avatar
for a virtual world created by super
social you might have an avatar that is
in a completely different setup
right maybe you have your own multiple
digital identities
how are we going to communicate and
interact as
individuals with these different avatars
which is an amazing thing to
think about and how can we allow you
michael as a person to have multiple
digital identities and avatar each of
whom serve you differently in the
virtual world
and then as a as an outcome of that what
are the relationships that you're going
to have
with different people around the world
right and how do we make sure that
society will continue to be a respectful
everyone talks about you know
cyberbullying right
i think this is going to be an even
bigger challenge when we talk about a
world where
maybe there are 7 billion people but
there might be 17 billion avatars
represented by these individuals right
so you're talking about an explosion of
identities
mostly in the digital sphere and i think
how do we build society to continue and
be a place of respect
and and using technologies in a
meaningful way i think that's a big big
question that obviously
we're not going to attack and address
ourselves as a company
and i think that's one thing the second
thing is as i've mentioned we started
super social in the middle of a pandemic
so we're building a 100
remote and distributed organization how
do you build team
that are united that are collected that
pursue the same vision in the same
values and culture
this is something that we are writing
the playbook on the go we don't have all
the answers but we started as a remote
team and i think work
life will come back to some normality
and people will get back to offices at
some point
but i think it's now going to be some
form of a hybrid and i'm really really
excited i'm really excited as a ceo
to figure out what is the what is that
new playbook looks like for the next
decade no one has wrote that playbook so
i'm excited about figuring that piece
out
how do you continuously empower and
inspire your team
and build a large-scale global
organization that is remote and
distributed
and making people feel connected in one
unit
i'm excited about that what i'm
particularly inspired by
throughout these 20 minutes is this
excitement mentality over
the the questions that have yet to be
answered whether it's how do you
responsibly create an environment in
which you know multiple identities
remain civil and remain you know honest
and and
with obviously all the dangers that you
know the digital
digitalized world brings to it and
getting excited about that getting
excited about this idea of remote we're
getting excited about not really knowing
like
having this vision not really knowing
you know what's gonna be there but how
do we
work together with others and with you
know gamers around the world to reach
that vision i think that
that excitement and that is true
entrepreneurship that is true leadership
and it's infectious i have to say right
i mean i'm sure that people that are
working with you and they're saying
like you know it doesn't like it doesn't
matter what problem we come up with
because we're excited about those
problems we're excited about how we're
going to solve them
we're going to be hands-on in solving
them and we're going to be intentional
about solving them
it feels to me that so many you know
tend to to you know other sugar coat
stuff or to
shrug it off and say okay we'll deal
with that later we we don't want to like
to talk about it too much but here
you're saying
no i'm excited about these problems i'm
excited about them as opportunities
and and i think that's that's just
remarkable jonathan what what really
gets you going
in the morning like what like what makes
you sleep well at night or not well
like what really gets you excited about
what you're doing here
i think what i'm what i get excited by
every morning for the past decade since
i
started my entrepreneurial journey is
creating the impossible is
is creating the one thing that you think
to be impossible
and bringing people around it right at
the end of the day
you know our number one company value is
super social is team is literally
everything
our flywheel starts and ends with the
team if you have amazing people
and they're motivated and they're
excited about a vision and you build an
environment where they can be the best
version of themselves
you have really good chances of changing
the world and i think that's the core of
what i do as an entrepreneur
i'm excited about the future the vision
the world we can help create
as as a company and i bring really
amazing people together
and empower them to create that future
because that's the only way to do that
i'm not gonna build it on my own
um and and that's that's what keeps me
going in the morning that could
what keeps me working so hard i spend a
huge amount of my time
finding those people ex getting them
excited getting them committed
helping them grow i think this is the
job of leadership and the job of
entrepreneurs and you know when people
join us i tell them look
i might be your boss but you're my
teacher i'm going to learn from you more
than you're going to learn from me and
my job is to help you be
the most successful you can be because
if you do that we can actually
succeed and that's what gets me excited
every morning
[Music]
thank you so much for the inspiration i
i just love it
i i mean it's really it's a i just love
what you're doing
i love your your your motivations i love
your execution
the products everything so thank you for
joining my show was a phenomenal
the most important question three words
that you would use to describe yourself
optimistic
determination and love
yonatan stay safe and stay healthy
enjoy columbus ohio and i really hope to
see you in person
in one of the virtual worlds wherever it
may be but continue
seeing you thank you very much
you